as your country's top spy you must
infiltrate the headquarters of the evil
syndicate find the secret control panel
and deactivate their death ray but all
you have to go on is the following
information picked up by your
surveillance team the headquarters is a
massive pyramid with a single room at
the top level two rooms on the next and
so on the control panel is hidden behind
a painting on the highest floor that can
satisfy the following conditions each
room has exactly three doors to three
other rooms on that floor except the
control panel room which connects to
only one there are no hallways and you
can ignore stairs unfortunately you
don't have a floor plan and you'll only
have enough time to search a single
floor before the alarm system
reactivates can you figure out which
floor the control room is on to solve
this problem we need to visualize it
for starters we know that on the correct
floor there is one room let's call it
room a with one door to the control
panel room plus one door two room B and
one to C so there must be at least four
rooms which we can represent as circles
drawing lines between them for the
doorways but once we connect rooms B and
C there are no other connections
possible so the fourth floor down from
the top is out
we know the control panel has to be as
high up as possible so let's make our
way down the pyramid the fifth highest
floor doesn't work either we can figure
that out by drawing it but to be sure we
haven't missed any possibilities here's
another way every door corresponds to a
line in our graph that makes two rooms
in two neighbors so in the end there
have to be an even number of neighbors
no matter how many connections we make
on the fifth highest floor to fulfill
our starting conditions we need four
rooms with three neighbors each plus the
control panel room with one neighbor
which makes 13 total neighbors since
that's an odd number it's not possible
fact this also rules out every floor
that has an odd number of rooms so let's
go one more floor down when we draw out
the rooms lo and behold we can find an
arrangement that works like this
incidentally the study of such visual
models that show the connections and
relationships between different objects
is known as graph theory in a basic
graph the circles representing the
objects are known as nodes while the
connecting lines are called edges
researchers studying such graphs ask
questions like how far is this node from
that one how many edges does the most
popular node have is there a route
between these two nodes and if so how
long is it graphs like this are often
used to map communication networks but
they can represent almost any kind of
network from transport connections
within a city and social relationships
among people to chemical interactions
between proteins or the spread of an
epidemic through different locations so
armed with these techniques back to the
pyramid you avoid the guards and
security cameras infiltrate the sixth
floor from the top find the hidden panel
pull some conspicuous levers and send
the death-rate crashing into the ocean
now time to solve the mystery of why
your surveillance team always gives you
cryptic information hi everybody if you
liked this riddle try solving these two
you